So when we remove the keyword, self, from in front
of storyline. Let me go ahead and do that one
more time. What we are really doing is changing storyline
from being an instance variable, accessible with instances like Toy
Story and Avatar, to being a simple local variable inside
the function init. Now, I will still be able
to access this variable, storyline, from anywhere inside this function
in it. But not with an instance like Avatar. And
since we are attempting to do that in
this print statement, my hypothesis is that Python will
throw an error and say that this movie object
Avatar has no storyline. So to check that
hypothesis, I will save my media file, and
then go back to my entertainment_center file and
run that file. There is the error. Python says
that Movie instance, in this case, Avatar, has no
attribute called storyline. So, to correct this, what I will do, is go
back to the code and add the self keyword in front of storyline, there.